So, wow, you now understand a lot.
You understand the variance which is the spread of the data squared.
You understand standard deviation which is the same without the square,
and the other way to compute all of those in a single pass to the data
using only these running counters.
Let's try it profound. You're really deep into statistics now.
So, let me ask you two tricky questions.
This is a secret, please don't tell anybody, but I'm actually considering, at least hypothetically,
to give everybody a raise, and we're lucky to ask is what the effect of the raise is
on the mean and standard deviation of the distribution of salaries in the company.
I'm considering two types of raises, a fixed amount of $1000
and what's called of relative raise of 20%.
Now, that changes the mean and/or the standard deviation to potentially different values
they call µ’ and σ’ and the changes either multiplicative,
which would be the factor over here, or additive.
If there is no multiplicative change, just put one over here.
Can you guess what the effect is of adding $1000 to your salary
on the mean and the standard deviation?